Hello, folks.
Welcome to the
neuroanatomy lecture
on cerebrovascular
anatomy, where
we will cover
gross blood supply
of the CNS, the brain
and the spinal cord. My
name is Vinci Matthew.
I am one of your academic
medicine scholars
on the research track.
Some of you guys
might remember me
from OMM and DPR last
semester. And I want
to thank Dr. Jennifer
G, who is at the Arkansas
campus, for giving
me this opportunity
to give this lecture.
I'm very excited to
give this lecture
because I love
neuroanatomy and neuro in
general. Hopefully
I can use some of my
passion into this
lecture and get you guys
excited about it
too. I know some of
you guys are intimidated
by neuroanatomy,
rightfully so, but
I want to try and
make it easier for
you guys to understand
this maybe a
little humongous
topic that cerebrovascular
anatomy is.
And I've tried to
do that by bringing
in the clinical
aspects of
what you guys will
see in third year,
fourth year, and
if you go into
neuro in the future.
So I've tried to make
everything as clinical
and as board relevant
as possible, but there
are some things in
anatomy that you just
have to wrote, memorize,
that you can later
on apply it. So if
you have any questions
regarding any of the
topics covered in this
lecture, please feel
free to email me here.
I'm always
available to Zoom
or answer your
emails on it.
I've tried to
include some clinical
questions and my
exam questions
will be similar to
that. So trying to
make it more
clinical as I can be.
Here are my references.
I want you guys to
focus on the NOLTEs,
The Human Brain and the
First Aid USMLE Step
1, 2024. The NOLTEs is
the primary textbook for
neuroanatomy and it's
available on the library
database and also
multiple copies in the
med school library.
For the first aid
book, I have actually
included a picture
of this book on
the corners of some
of the slides. Those
are important board
-tested topics. So
I've tried to
highlight it and they
will be coming over
and over again as
you guys start studying
for the boards.
So this is a kind
of time where you
guys can start looking
into first aid,
kind of get familiar
with the board
stuff. It's never
too early to start.
Here are your
session objectives.
So by the end of the
lecture, you guys
should be comfortable
naming these arteries,
identifying these
arteries on the
brain in the picture,
in a cadaver picture,
or an animated
cartoon picture. So
we'll go through all
of these in detail.
And for each of
these arteries,
when we talk about it,
try to see, can you
identify the parent
vessels? Where does this
artery come from? So
if you're talking
about common carotid
artery, where does the
common carotid artery
originate from? On the
right and the left.
Where is it going? Is
the common carotid going
to a specific region
in the brain, or is
it giving a branch
that goes further into?
And what are the
neurovascular structures
that are related to
it? So we'll talk about
the common carotid artery
in the neck and the
venous structure,
internal jugular vein,
the nervous structure,
the vagus nerve associated
with it, and what
part of the brain
does it supply to? So
each of these arteries,
don't just think of
them isolated, try to
think of them relative
to the other structures
and its functions.
Where is it coming from?
Where is it going to?
What is it feeding?
This is an important
picture that you guys
want to have an
understanding of by the
end of this lecture.
If you guys understand
this portion, then
I have done my job.
And as you can see
I've put a picture of
the first aid and that
is indicating that
this is a heavily
tested topic on the step
one and for that matter
step two as well.
So by the end of the
lecture you guys should
be able to identify
the anterior
circulation versus the
posterior circulation.
What are the arteries
of those circulation?
What part of the brain
are they feeding?
So there are four ways
blood can enter your
brain. So the anterior
circulation provided
by the two internal
carotid arteries gives
about 80% of the
blood supply. And the
posterior circulation
given by your vertebral
arteries, two vertebral
arteries, that provides
about 20% of the
supply. So you have
your angiogram picture
here. In the green, you
can see the two internal
carotid arteries
coming off of the common
carotid that splits
into internal and
external carotid. And
then you have the two
arteries in the red,
which is your vertebral
arteries, coming off
of your subclavian
arteries. The internal
carotid provides the
telencephalon, the
diencephalon, and the
vertebral arteries provides
the diencephalon and
the brainstem, which
is the midbrain, pons,
the medulla, and the
cerebellum. These
anterior and posterior
circulations are connected
in the brain through
a very important artery
called the posterior
communicating
arteries. So this is
another pictorial
representation of what portions
of the brain does the
anterior circulation
given by the two
internal carotid arteries
and the posterior
circulation given by the
two vertebral arteries
provide. So we have
the telencephalon giving
the cerebrohemispheres,
basal ganglia, the
diencephalon giving
the thalamus and the
hypothalamus, which
are mainly supplied by
your internal carotid
arteries. And then you
have your mesencephalon,
metencephalon, the
myencephalon, mainly
provided by the two
vertebral arteries.
So now we'll talk
in depth on anterior
circulation, which I
mentioned is provided
by the two internal
carotid arteries.
So let's look at where
the internal carotid
artery comes from. So
you have the ascending
aorta and its four
main branches, right
from the heart. The
mnemonic is ABCs,
ascending aorta,
brachiocephalic, common carotid,
and the S4 subclavian
artery. So your
right common carotid comes
from the brachiocephalic
artery. The left
common carotid comes
directly off of the
arch of the aorta. So
we have the left and the
right common carotid.
It ascends through
the neck and at the
level of C4 cervical
vertebra, it bifurcates
or bifurcates into
internal carotid and
the external carotid.
So the internal carotid
moves posterior laterally,
and the external
carotid moves medially
and anteriorly,
and the internal carotid
enters the skull,
whereas the external
carotid stays outside.
I just put this slide
so that you guys can
appreciate the anatomy
of internal carotid
artery and the vertebral
artery relative
to each other in real
life. So on the right
is the angiographic
picture and on the
left you guys can
compare it to the cartoon
labeled with the with
the different structures
and what you guys
see in your textbooks
and online with the
cartoon version is
exactly the actual
drawing of what we have
in real life anatomy
so on the green
again is your internal
carotid artery coming
off of the common
carotid at the level of
C4 vertebra, and the
red is your vertebral
arteries coming off
of the subclavian,
and they join in the
middle to form the
basilar artery, which
we will soon talk about.
Your two internal
carotid arteries travel
on the side of the
neck in what's called
the carotid sheath.
So inside the carotid
sheath, you have
the internal carotid
artery, you have the
internal jugular vein,
and you have the
vagus nerve traveling
inside it together.
And at the level of C4,
it again bifurcates
into your internal
carotid artery and
external carotid artery.
The internal carotid
artery travels
inside the skull through
the carotid canal,
which is the
petrospersion of your
temporal bone. And
once the internal
carotid artery is
inside the skull, it's
called intracranial
ICA, and outside the
cranium, it's called
extracranial ICA.
And then the
intracranial ICA travels
through the cavernous
sinus, which we
will talk about in
the future slides.
So here you can see
the cavernous sinus.
It's a venous structure.
And that's next
to a bony structure
called the cellotorcyca
inside the brain.
The cellotorcyca is
the bone where your
pituitary sits in, which
you guys will also
learn in the future.
And then it enters,
traverses the
dura. So you have
the dura we talked
about in the
menageal lecture.
Once the ICA is
inside the dura, it's
called the intradural
ICA. And then the
intradural ICA gives
off four important
branches, which has
a mnemonic OPAM. So
you have the
ophthalmic artery, you
have the posterior
communicating artery,
anterior cerebral
artery, and middle
cerebral artery,
all of which
are very important
to talk about.
the four intradural
branches of ICA are
heavily tested on all
kinds of exams you'll
be ****** on it on your
third year clinicals
as well so those are
your what's known
as the opam mnemonic
ophthalmic artery right
here it's the first
branch coming off
another heavily tested
question what is the
first branch of the
intradural ICA so that's
your ophthalmic artery
the small one right
here. And then the
ICA gives off your
posterior communicating
artery, which we
talked about before, is
the artery that connects
your anterior
circulation and the
posterior circulation. So
you have your posterior
communicating artery.
And then the two
terminal branches
of your ICA, the big
branches are your middle
cerebral artery that
goes laterally into
the brain, and the
anterior cerebral
artery that gives blood
supply to the anterior
portion of the brain.
Another thing that
attendings often like to
ask is the branches
of internal carotid
artery in the neck. It
actually doesn't give
any branches. That's
one way you can
differentiate between
the ICAN and the ECA when
you're looking at any
radiological images.
The ECA has many branches
in the neck, whereas
the ICA, the internal
carotid artery, has
no branches in the
neck. It does have
branches once it traverses
the skull, which is
the intracranial ICA.
The intracranial ICA
has branches which you
guys are not required
to know and then it
has four main branches
once it traverses the
dura so that's the
intradural branches
so keep those in mind.
The first branch
of your intradural
ICA is your ophthalmic
artery and it
travels with the
optic nerve and the
ophthalmic vein
through the optic
canal or the
optic foramen to
supply the eye as
the name suggests
And since this is the
first branch of the
intradural ICA, so you
can imagine a thrombus
or an emboli coming
from the heart that
travels through the
internal carotid artery, it
can easily get
dislodged in this tiny
bifurcation here.
So the occlusion
of the ophthalmic
artery, which is
symptomatic, which can
be symptomatic, is
called a morosis fugax.
It's a very heavily
tested topic. And this
happens when there
is transient ischemic
attack or TIAs, which are
a harbinger for strokes
that can happen later.
So patients often
describe this as a
transient planeless vision
loss due to the lack
of perfusion of the
ophthalmic artery. And
people say it's like
a curtain, like a shade
coming over my eye.
And this is a very
important symptom to
look out for when
patients come in, because
this can indicate
that they might have
already had a ******
or can have strokes in
the future. We will
talk about this more in
the cerebrovascular
lecture in pathology.
The second branch of
the intradural ICA
is the posterior
communicating artery,
which is indicated
in yellow here,
connecting the orange,
which is the anterior
circulation, and the
blue, or the cyan,
is the posterior
circulation. And the
PCOM is very important
And the patency
of PCOM is important
so that we know
that the anterior
circulation communicates
with the posterior
circulation.
Often, there are people
who only have one
patent posterior
communicating artery. And
sometimes that's enough.
As long as you have at
least one patent
posterior communicating
artery, your anterior
posterior circulation
can communicate and have
collaterals. But you
can imagine somebody who
has a left hypoplastic
posterior communicating
artery then gets
a ****** that occludes
the right posterior
communicating artery,
then you're at a major
risk of having an
anterior or a posterior
circulation ******,
which can be very fatal.
The anterior of the
terminal branches
of internal carotid
artery is your
anterior cerebral
artery or ACA.
It is a very important
big branch of
the ICA that supplies
your anterior
and medial portions
of the brain.
And this bifurcation
of the ICA, which is
right here, it happens
under the frontal
lobe in the medial
portion of your sylvian
fissure. So you can
see the sylvian fissure
right here. That's
the separation of your
frontal lobe from
temporal lobe. So the
ICA bifurcates into ACA
or anterior cerebral
artery and MCA or
the middle cerebral
artery in the medial
portion of the cillian
fissure under the
frontal lobe. And the ACA
travels on top of your
optic chiasm which
you can see right
here. So I want you to
appreciate the structures,
the neurovascular
structures near it.
So you have your
ACA traveling on top
looping around the optic
chiasm and the optic
nerve. and then it
travels along the
interhemispheric longitudinal
fissure, and it
travels anteriorly.
And so you have your
left ACA and your
right ACA, which
communicates with each other
through your anterior
communicating
artery, which is a very
small but very important
artery that communicates
your left and
right frontal lobes,
basically, as the
left and right ACA
supplies your left and
right medial portions
of the frontal lobe.
And the main supply
of your medial and
anterior portion of
the frontal, temporal,
and parietal regions
comes from the ACA.
So it's quite an
important branch of ICA.
So let's focus on this
picture right here.
This is straight from
your USMLE Step 1 book
from the neurology
portion, a very heavily
tested topic. So let's
look at what it's
showing so you have
three pictures of the
brain on the left on
the first the first one
is you're you're seeing
the brain from the
left side the whole
cerebrum from the left
side the middle picture
is a mid-sagital
cut of the brain and
the final picture is a
inferior view of the
brain and focusing on
the anterior cerebral
artery that's your
yellow so you can see
how it provides blood
supply to the anterior
portion of your frontal
lobe and the top
portions of your parietal
lobe. And in the
mid-sagital cut, you
can see how it provides
extensive blood supply
to the medial portions
of the frontal
lobe. So you can see it
all over here, medial
portions of the parietal
lobe, and also you
have the anterior
portion of the corpus
callosum, the white
matter tract that connects
your left and right
cerebral hemispheres,
and the gyri that
goes over it, your
cingulate gyrus. And in
the inferior cut, you
can appreciate how the
anterior cerebral artery
provides blood supply
to the gyri ******
or the straight gyri
of the frontal lobe.
And in this cartoon
picture, again, a mid
-sagital cut, you can
see how the ACA medially
branches from the
ICA and travels
anteriorly. And this
big branch goes around
your cingulate gyrus,
again, Again, your
pericolosal artery, you
guys will see that in
your neuroanatomy lab,
not required to know
for my lecture. And
you can see, again,
extensive branching of
the ACA medially going
up and providing blood
supply to the medial
portions of your
precentral gyrus or your
motor cortex and your
postcentral gyrus,
your medial portions of
the postcentral gyrus
are the somatosensory
cortex. You can see
it here, the medial
frontal lobe and medial
somatosensory cortex.
And another thing that
I want you guys to
appreciate is that you
can see how the ACA is
coming on top of the
optic chiasm. So the
ACA travels above the
optic nerve and the
chiasm. That's an important
anatomical mark to
understand and know,
especially during
neurosurgical procedures.
And finally, you have
the largest terminating
branch of ICA, the
middle cerebral artery.
And as we mentioned,
again, the middle
cerebral artery is the
bifurcation going laterally
from the ICA. Again,
the bifurcation
happens under the frontal
lobe medial to the
sylvian fissure. So
the sylvian fissure is,
again, that separation
between your frontal
lobe and temporal lobe.
And you can see your
ICA coming in through
the neck enters
interdurally, first
gives off the ophthalmic
artery, then the posterior
communicating artery,
and then medially it
gives off the anterior
cerebral artery, and
laterally it gives
off the middle cerebral
artery. And the middle
cerebral artery
travels through that
sylvian fissure between
your, that fissure
between the frontal and
temporal lobe, and then
it travels around
your, that fifth hidden
lobe, the insular
cortex. And once it wraps
around the insular
cortex, then it comes out
of the lobe and then
wraps around the lateral
parts of the cortex,
giving off the major
cortical branches that
supplies the lateral
portions of your
frontal, temporal, and
parietal lobes. So again,
take a look at this
picture. Again, your
ICA comes in and
laterally the MCA bifurcates.
The M1 branch goes
through the sylvian
fissure, the M2 branch
goes through the insular
cortex, wraps around,
and the M4 comes out
cortically, giving
off the cortical
branches. The M1, M2, M3,
M4 branches I just
mentioned for the complete
net sakes, you guys
are not tested on it.
So again, important to
understand the middle
cerebral artery
provides much of the
supply for the lateral
parts of the frontal
lobe, your parietal
lobe, and your temporal
lobe. So remember,
you have the motor and
sensory homunculus,
the lateral portions,
those are supplied
by your MCA branches.
A very important
clinical vignette of the
MCA is that they have
these tiny arteries
of the MCA called
the lenticulostriate
arteries, as you can
see here. They supply
the basal ganglia.
Basal ganglia is a
collection of nucleus,
subcortical gray matter,
and these lenticulostriate
arteries, which
are branches of
MCA, because they're
tiny and have thin
walls, in cases of
uncontrolled, untreated
hypertension, they can
have this bulging because
the small arteries
are subjected to high
pressure. So they
can balloon out. And
at one point, they
can hemorrhage, causing
hemorrhagic ******.
And when they do,
they're called Chakot
-Bouchard aneurysms,
very heavily tested
topic. And these Chakot
-Bouchard aneurysms,
these hemorrhagic
strokes have a
classic presentation
on a CT. So
this here is a
CT of the brain.
And you can see the
white on a CT usually
indicate hemorrhage,
acute blood. So
this is an acute bleed
in the basal ganglia
region. That is a
classic presentation,
classic radiology
of Chakot-Buschard
aneurysms, which you
see in an uncontrolled
hypertensive patient.
um that was a
hemorrhagic ****** but
these lenticulostriate
arteries are also
prone to get ischemic
strokes this is when
you have a an emboli
or thrombus distalging
from your heart
and can get stuck in
these tiny vessels
and can cut off blood
supply to basal ganglia
in that region
which then causes
ischemia and can further
cause infarction and
in an mri so this is
a t2 weighted MRI.
I know this is T2
because in T2 your fluid,
your CSF is white.
So I can look at
the ventricles and
see the ventricles are
white so that I know
this is a T2 weighted
MRI. If the ventricles
are black on
the other hand then
it's a T1 weighted MRI.
So on a T2 weighted
MRI you'll see what's
called a lacuna
****** or lake-like.
It looks like a
white lake in a black
black surrounding.
So that is a ischemic
****** of the lenticular
striate arteries,
which are both of these
are heavily tested.
And we'll talk about
it more further
in the cerebrovascular
pathology lecture.
So now that we have
talked about the terminal
branches of ICA,
the anterior ACA,
anterior cerebral artery,
and your lateral MCA,
middle cerebral
artery, we can further
look into their blood
supply regions. So
because ACA supplies
your medial portions of
the frontal lobe,
specifically the somatosensory
cortex in the
parietal lobe and the
motor cortex in the
frontal lobe, your
precentral gyrus and
your postcentral gyrus,
you know the motor and
the sensory homunculus.
The homunculus is
basically how different
portions of the
motor and the sensory
cortex correlate to
different portions of the
body that's supplied
to. So the medial
portion of both motor and
the sensory homunculus
is your leg and your
trunk. So your leg
and your trunk, because
the medial portions
are supplied by your
ACA, if you have an
ACA ******, ischemic
or hemorrhagic ******,
then you can expect
your leg and your trunk
to be affected.
Whereas your lateral
portions of your motor
and sensory cortex, that
correlates to your
hand and your face,
and those are supplied
by your middle cerebral
artery. So then you
can expect a ******,
either ischemic or
hemorrhagic ******, to
affect your, when it's
affecting the MCA,
it will have deficits
in your face and your
hands. That's how when
somebody comes in to
the ER, they have
******-like symptoms,
you actually try to see
where in the body are
they having the ******
-like symptoms, then
you can easily correlate
to what part of
the brain is a patient
having a ****** on.
So now take a quick
second, or not a second,
quick two minutes,
and go through the
intradural branches of
your ICA, which makes
up the anterior
circulation, go through
each of them and try
to answer these four
questions. If you
can, then you've done
a good job in understanding
and memorizing
the concept that we
talked about so far.
We'll now talk
about the posterior
circulation, which
we mentioned is
supplied by the two
vertebral arteries
that enters posteriorly
and supplies
the posterior
regions of the brain.
The two vertebral
arteries originate
from the two subclavian
arteries that comes
off of the aorta,
and they get their
name, vertebral
arteries, because they
travel through the
transverse foramen
of the C6 through C1
cervical vertebra.
So that's why you
can see here the
vertebral arteries
traveling through the
transverse foramen of
C6 through C1, and they
enter the cranium
via the foramen
magnum, which is that
big opening through
which your spinal
cord travels, and they
enter lateral and
anterior to the brainstem,
and near the
pontomedullary junction,
they fuse to form
the basilar artery.
The branches of the
vertebral arteries plus
the basilar arteries
together are called the
vertebro-basilar system,
and they give the
posterior circulation
infratentorially. So
everything below the
tentorium, which separates
the cerebellum and
the cerebrum right
here, that is supplied
by the vertebral basilar
system. And
supratentorially, that's your
posterior cerebral
artery. So the two
vertebral arteries comes
posterior laterally. So
you can see it traveling
posteriorly, looping
around. And then it
comes anteriorly to
the brainstem. and around
the point of medullary
junction, the two
vertebral arteries
fuse together to form
the one basilar artery.
Before it becomes the
basilar artery, the
vertebral artery
gives off two main
branches. So you have
the anterior spinal
artery coming off
of the two vertebral
artery becoming one and
you have one anterior
spinal artery that
supplies blood to
the ventral portion
of the spinal cord.
And then you have two
posterior inferior
cerebellar artery, or
most often just referred
to as pica, that
comes off of the two
vertebral arteries. So
here is your pica here
that, as the name
suggests, supplies most of
the posterior lobe of
the cerebellum here.
And then the two
vertebrals join together,
and the first
branch coming off of
that is your anterior
inferior cerebellar
artery or the ICA. So
if there's a posterior
inferior then it
has to be anterior
inferior. So the
anterior inferior
cerebellar artery as the
name suggests supplies
most the inferior
portions of the
anterior lobe of the
cerebellum right here.
And then you have
these tiny small
branches coming
off of the basilar
called the pontine
arteries that
supplies the
blood to the pons.
And finally, you
have the superior
cerebellar artery that
supplies most of the
superior medial and
superior lateral
cerebellum. So most
of the cerebellum is
supplied by the superior
cerebellar artery.
And then the terminal
branches of the
basilar system forms
the PCA which is not
part of the vertebral
basilar system.
I just thought I'd
include a angiographic
variant from my own
research. You guys
are not tested on
this. I just thought
this was cool. So we
expect the pica which
is a posterior inferior
cerebellar artery
to come from the
vertebral artery and
the aica which is
the anterior inferior
cerebellar artery to
come from the basilar
artery. But in this
angiographic variant,
which has never been
reported before,
we saw that the left
pica here came from the
basilar artery, and
it came distal to the
left aica, which is
never, never reported.
And the right pica
actually came directly from
the right SCA, the
superior cerebellar
artery. So this just
goes to show that
cerebrovasculature is very
diverse. And especially
the posterior circulation
and especially the
cerebellar arteries are
reported to be very,
very variant. So it's
important to understand
the normal anatomy,
but when you look at
the clinical images,
it might not correlate.
And these are important
to know because then
if there's ****** of
any of these arteries,
it can affect the
patient different than
what you normally
expect it to. So this is
just a cool thing for
you guys to appreciate.
Finally, the terminal
branch of the basilar
artery is your PCA or
your posterior cerebral
artery. So you can
see the basilar artery
giving its last
bifurcation terminal branch
of the PCA. It goes
around and supplies the
inferior and medial
portions of the occipital
lobe. So it wraps
around the middle
midbrain over here and
then goes and supplies the
occipital lobe. So
look at the branching.
And the PCA is
supratentorial. So we talked
about the tentorium
cerebelli, which is that
dural fold that separates
the cerebrum from
the cerebellum. So PCA
supplies the posterior
parts of the brain
supratentorially, and
the vertebral basilar
system that we talked
about is infratentorial
and supplies the
posterior circulation
below the tentorium. And
also look at the neural
structure that goes
in between your PCA
and your superior
cerebellar artery, SCA.
So that, also appreciate
here, I put this
picture, so here is your
posterior cerebral
artery and your superior
cerebellar artery, and
you have your cranial
nerve 3 that comes in
between. So imagine
this is your PCA, this
is your SCA, your cranial
nerve 3 goes in between.
So you can imagine
a medial aneurysm
of either of these
arteries, PCA or SCA,
it can compress on the
oculomotor nerve, and
that usually happens when
there's an aneurysmal
rupture of either of
those two arteries, the
patients can present
with oculomotor nerve
palsies with the
extraocular muscles not
working. So that's an
important clinical
vignette to keep in mind.
Now I want to talk
about these special
regions of the brain
that are kind of
exceptions to the areas
that we talked about
in that they don't
get blood supply from
one specific cerebral
artery. Instead, they
get kind of end zone
blood supply from
two different cerebral
arteries. And these
are called watershed
areas. So instead
of one artery, like
let's say ACA providing
all the blood supply,
they get kind of
the end blood supply
from ACA, MCA, or
MCA, PCA. They're kind
of like your middle
child that doesn't
get enough attention.
And because they are
kind of like these border
zones that get end
blood supply from the
ends of two different
cerebral arteries,
during times of global
hypoperfusion, they might
not get enough blood
supply because the
blood supply is going
to bigger areas that are
supplied by each of
the arteries. They're
not getting enough love.
So they are prone to
infarction or ******,
****** and infarction
during global hypoverfusion.
So you have two
big regions. They call
the cortical watershed
zones. So you have
in the, these are T1
-weighted MRIs. I know
it's T1 because the CSF
is black. So in this
T1-weighted MRI, you
can see the anterior
cortical watershed area.
So this is a region
supplied by the ACA and
MCA, and there's the
posterior cortical
watershed area region
supplied by MCA and PCA.
And these on D is your
paramedian watershed
area, which are supplied
by MCA and ACA, and
the deep or the
subcortical watershed zone
supplied by ACA and MCA.
So below, you can see
the white in the T1
weighted MRI is showing
the stroked out
regions. So this patient
might have had a global
hypotensive episode
where they stroked out
this region that was
supplied by MCA and PCA,
this subcortical region
that was supplied by
ACA and MCA, and again,
same thing, this
paramedian structure that
was supplied by ACA
and PCA, ACA and MCA.
Also, another board
-relevant topic.
Finally, you have
the spinal arteries,
which comes off of the
vertebral artery that
we mentioned. So you
have the two vertebral
arteries giving
the anterior spinal
artery that becomes one
that travels ventrally
and supplies the
anterior spinal cord.
So you can see
there's one anterior
spinal artery. And
the posterior inferior
cerebellar artery
supplies the posterior
inferior spinal artery.
Remember the pica,
posterior inferior
cerebellar artery, comes
off of the two
vertebral arteries and
they give off the
posterior inferior spinal
artery. So there's
two posterior spinal
arteries and one
anterior spinal artery.
And because the
anterior spinal artery
supplies the ventral,
anterior portions
of the spinal cord,
it supplies the
motor part of the
spinal cord. And the
posterior inferior
spinal artery supplies
the sensory part
of the spinal cord.
So now that we've talked
about the anterior
and posterior circulation
in depth, we can
finally talk about the
circle of villus which
is basically a circular
network of arteries
at the base of the
brain and they provide
a collateral circulation
and they're formed
by the anterior and
posterior circulation
and the main player in
connecting everything
the anterior and the
posterior is your
posterior communicating
artery or the PCOM. So
they basically act as a
safeguard so let's say
there is the ******
of the artery on the
right side in the
frontal region as long as
you have a patent
anterior, a patent circle
of villus, there's still
collaterals to come
through from other
parts of the brain that
can still provide that
******, that region.
And the circle of
villus, also called
the cow, endearingly,
although I would
not use that word
in a clinical
setting. People don't
like that, especially
neurosurgeons don't
like that word.
The circle of villus
is a common site of
development of what's
called aneurysm. And
usually when we
talk about aneurysm,
we're referring to a
saccular or bary aneurysms.
And if they rupture
from the circular
villus, they go into
the subarachnoid
space and causes
subarachnoid hemorrhage.
And there is a very,
very large amount
of anatomical
variation of circular
villus. And we see
that throughout when we
do CTAs or angiograms.
And only 30 to
50% of individuals
have a fully patented
circle of villus. So
as I said, mentioned
before, if you have
any hypoplastic
right posterior
communicating artery,
as long as there is a
patent left posterior
communicating
artery, all of the
brain will still get
blood supply because
of the beautiful
circle of the list.
At this point of time,
you guys should be
able to look at this
picture and be able
to identify all the
arteries that I have
highlighted in the
red. This will be an
important slide to
remember for both
your comp and for your
future board exams.
I put this picture to
kind of challenge you
guys. Can you look at
this CT angiogram, CTA,
and identify, kind of
orient yourself and
identify the structures.
So you can cleanly
see the circle of villus
in the CTA, but are
you able to identify
this? This is also a
good way to kind of
get you guys thinking
clinically and get used
to looking at radiological
images that you will
see in your third
-year clinicals, even
though if you don't end
up going into neuro,
you'll be kind of asked
to look at it and maybe
judge what you see.
So here's the
highlighted labeled
version of the CTA
that, you know,
you can look at
your own time. You
won't be tested on
this particularly.
So take a couple of
minutes and think through
the different arteries
that we talked about
that makes up the
infratentorial and
supratentorial posterior
circulation, and can you
answer these four
questions for each of
these arteries. If you
can, then you're ready
to move on to the next
portion. So we talked
in depth about the
arterial supply of the
brain. Now we'll shift
gears and talk about
the venous drainage of
the brain. We'll cover
the cerebral sinuses,
deep cerebral veins,
and the superficial
cerebral veins. So on
the right here is a
angiogram of the brain.
I've been kind of
introducing you guys to
radiological images
that you will be exposed
to in your clinical.
So I showed you guys
CT of the brain, CTA,
MRI, and here's an
angiogram, which is
basically you inject a
dye into the femoral
artery and then it travels
through the aorta and
pumps into the ICA
and the vertebral
arteries and it lights
up the arteries and
veins of the brain and
you're basically taking
continuous x-rays.
So first you will see
the arterial system
and after a while you
see the dye going through
the arterial system
and draining through
the venous system. So
this image was taken
when the artery was
going through the venous
system. So you can
see the main sinuses
of the brain and some
of the veins that we
will talk in depth in
the next few slides.
One of the main parts
of the cerebrovenous
system is the cerebral
sinuses, appropriately
called dural sinuses,
because they are
enfoldings, channels
created by the enfoldings
of the dura. So
here you can see the
superior sagittal sinus,
this hole that is formed
by the periosteal
dura and the meningeal
dura. So you have
the foc cerebrae that
comes down that forms
the superior sagittal
sinus, and the foc
cerebrae comes down through
the longitudinal
fissure and joins the
tentorium cerebelli
and forms that channel
here called the straight
sinus and laterally
you have the periosteal
dura that's joining
the tentorium cerebelli
to form the transfer
sinus. So they're
basically channels
formed by the dura mater
in foldings and they
carry the deoxygenated
blood. They're unlike
the veins because they
lack the three tunica
layers that the vein
has. They don't have
the valves and the
valves are simply dura
mater and they're
important in communicating
with the actual
venous system and the
CSF. So in this
picture, you can see the
arachnoid membranes here,
and that space is your
subarachnoid space.
That's where the CSF
is. So the CSF travels
through the subarachnoid
space, and there are
outpouchings into
the sinuses. These are
arachnoid outpouchings
called arachnoid
granulations or arachnoid
villi. This is how
the CSF communicates
with the subarachnoid
space into the sinuses.
So The CSF travels
through all the ventricles
and ends up in the
subarachnoid space
through the arachnoid
granulations and goes
into mainly the superior
sagittal sinus and
then they connect
through other sinuses
and ends up in the
internal jugular vein which
takes the venous blood,
including the CSF,
into the heart and
it gets reoxygenated.
So what are the cerebral
sinuses to know?
So the most important
one is your sagittal
sinus that goes
midline through that
sagittal suture that
you can see right
underneath the
sagittal suture is your
superior sagittal sinus
that traverses the
interhemispheric fissure
on top. It drains
the superficial
cortex. So these are
the tiny bridging
veins that you see that
drain into the superior
sagittal sinus.
And then parallel to
the superior sagittal
sinus inferiorly, draining
the more subcortical
brain and the
internal structure is
your inferior sagittal
sinus. And the inferior
sagittal sinus drains
into what's called
a straight sinus because
it looks straight.
And the superior
sagittal sinus and the
straight sinus meet
at the joining point
called the confluence
of sinus, also
called the torcular
heterophili. The torcular
heterophili then
drains into the
transverse sinus
where it means. So the
transverse sinus kind
of goes transversely
over the laterally,
the occipital lobe.
And the transverse
sinus then drains into
the sigmoid sinus,
which is the little
traversed sinus on
the below kind of near
the ear region. And the
sigmoid sinus finally
connects the sinus
system into the venous
system by draining into
the internal jugular
vein that exits the
skull through the
jugular foramen. You
also have the cavernous
sinus which is kind
of in deep and it's a
unique structure that
kind of drains the face
and the nose that we'll
talk further about.
This is a angiogram
of the left internal
cord artery so what
you're seeing is
the late venous phase
after the iodine dye
has filled through
the arterial phase.
This could be a
picture that you might
be asked to identify
during your exams.
In this picture,
I want you guys to
appreciate how the
superior sagittal sinus
drains these superficial
veins from the
cortex. So you have
some of the bridging
veins and the
superficial veins
draining into the
superior sagittal sinus.
You're unable to
appreciate the inferior
sagittal sinus
because the superior
sagittal sinus is
blocking the view.
The superior sagittal
sinus joins the
straight sinus medially
at the confluence
of sinuses, which
then drains into the
transverse sinus the
green, which then
meets up with your
sigmoid sinus in
the purple, and the
sigmoid sinus drains
both your superior
petrosal sinuses,
the cavernous
sinus, into it, and
then it all meets
at the jugular bulb
into the internal
jugular vein that
goes through the
jugular foramen.
The superior sagittal
sinus is formed
by the enfolding of
the foc cerebrae,
and it travels
enter immediately in
between the
intrahemispheric fissure
right underneath
that sagittal suture.
So this location is
very important in terms
of neurosurgical
interventions because when
you do any kind of
craniotomies, you try
to stay away from
that sagittal suture
because of the location
of superior sagittal
sinus, and you don't
want to accidentally
injure the superior
sagittal sinus because it
can be a very hard
complication to manage.
You'll get a lot
of venous bleed.
And you can see
these bridging
veins and the
cortical veins
that drain into the
superior sisal sinus.
It comes posteriorly
to join the confluence
of sinus, which then
drains into the transfer
sinus and then into
the sigmoid sinus.
These bridging
veins, injury to them
can cause subdural
hematoma that
we will talk about
in the future.
Once the venous blood
meets at the confluence
of sinus, then the
next path is through
the lateral sinuses,
called the transverse
sinus, which lies in
the lateral groove of
the occipital bone,
and it's mainly formed
by the periosteal
dura laterally and the
tentorium cerebellum,
cerebellum. The blood
then travels into
the sigmoid sinus at
that sigmoid transverse
junction. And finally,
through the sigmoid
sinus, it then joins
the internal jugular
vein, which exits the
skull through the
jugular foramen, which
also has multiple other
cranial nerves that
travels through it,
which are your vagus
nerve, your glucopharyngeal
nerve, and your
accessory nerve. So
that is an important
landmark during
neurosurgical procedures.
The cavernous sinus is a
unique dural
sinus system.
It is located on
the either side of
the cellotorsica,
which is that bony
structure that
contains pituitary
gland that we
talked about before.
It contains important
neurovascular structures,
including the cavernous
ICA that you can
see traveling through,
and multiple cranial
nerves. It has cranial
nerve 3, ocular motor
nerve, cranial nerve
4, trochlear nerve,
cranial nerve V1, V2,
the ophthalmic and
maxillary branch of
trigeminal nerve,
and cranial nerve 6,
the abducens nerve,
and it's the most
medially located in
the cavernous sinus.
So because of its
medial proximity,
anytime there's lesions
of the ICA or the
pituitary gland,
pituitary adenomas and
stuff, it can mainly
manifest as an
abducens nerve palsy.
The deep cerebral veins,
they drain the deep
structures of the
brain such as the basal
ganglia, thalamus,
and internal capsule.
There's the great cerebral
vein, vein of Galen,
internal cerebral
vein, basal veins of
Rosenthal, all of which
you don't have to memorize
by name. But what you
need to understand
is that the deep cerebral
vein mainly drain
into the inferior
sagittal sinus and mainly
to the straight sinus.
So that's the main
draining vein where
all the deep cerebral
veins come into and
the straight sinus then
meets the rest of the
sinus at the confluence
of sinus going to
then to the transverse
sinus into the sigmoid
sinus and the internal
jugular vein. The
straight sinus we talked
about earlier is formed
by that foc cerebri
coming down through
the inter-hemispheric
fissure and joining the
tentorium cerebelli.
The superficial cerebral
veins, there are
three that you should
know by name. There is
the superficial middle
cerebral vein, or the
sylvean vein, as you
can see it drain over
the sylvean fissure.
This is an important
landmark during sylvean
approach we go into
that parts the frontal
and the temporal lobe
during neurosurgical
interventions, and we
try to not injure these
veins, very important
draining veins. There's
the vein of Trollard,
or the superior
anastomotic cerebral
vein, which drains
both into the superior
sagittal sinus and also
into the vein of Labbe,
also called the inferior
anastomotic cerebral
vein, that mainly drains
into the transverse
sinus and then into
the sigmoid sinus.
Here is a DSA kind
of showing, sorry,
MRV, magnetic
resonance of the veins,
showing each of
those three veins.
Now that we have talked
about the drural sinuses,
the deep venous
system, and the
superficial venous
system, it's important
to put it together
to talk about
the overall direction
of drainage.
This is a very busy
slide, but it does show
you the direction of
drainage. So you have
the superior sagittal
sinus mainly draining
the superficial system
and the bridging veins.
And here's the
angiogram. Now you guys
can look at an angiogram
and know that it's an
angiogram, but this
is on the venous face.
So you can see these
tiny cortical veins and
the bridging veins
that are draining. So
these arrows are pointing
to the direction of
the drainage. So you
see the draining into
the superior sagittal
sinus. and then you
can see the internal
veins, the deep drainage
system, you can see
the inferior sagittal
sinus here connecting
into the straight sinus
as well as the other
deep veins draining
into the straight sinus
which all of which
then join at the
confluence of sinuses right
here and then once it
joins there it travels
through the transverse
sinus, right you see
the transverse sinus
here, as well as in the
lateral picture, you
see the transverse
sinus here that then
joins into the sigmoid
sinus, but finally
ends up in the internal
jugular vein at that
jugular bulb region and
exits the skull through
the jugular foramen.
An important pathology
of the venous system
is cerebrovenous
thrombosis, which is when
you have a blood clot
in the dural sinuses
or the cerebral veins,
which then causes
blocking of the venous
drainage from the brain.
On the right, you
have a MRV, magnetic
resonance imaging of the
vein. So you have the
gadolinium dye that's
lighting up the
superior sagittal sinus,
your right transfer
sinus, right sigmoid
sinus, and the internal
jugular vein. But you
don't see that happening
on the left side.
And this is because
you have a cerebrovenous
thrombosis of the
transverse sinus at
the junction of the
confluence of sinus.
So the classic board
presentation is a pregnant
lady coming in with
severe headache,
vomiting, and now she has
focal neurological
******-like symptoms.
Anytime there is
a risk factor of
hypercoagulose
states, which is seen
in pregnancy,
contraceptive use,
malignancy, inflammatory
diseases, you
have a high chance
of getting CVT.
So now take a
couple of minutes to
see if you can test
yourself in your
understanding of
cerebrovenous system
by going through
these four points.
Here's a clinical
question similar to what
you can expect in your
comp as well as board
exams, complex level
one and step one. Take
a few moments and see
if you can answer it.
So your brocus area
is your area of the
brain that controls
fluency of the speech. So
in the green, you can
see the brocus area
highlighted, which is
in the inferior frontal
gyrus. And it's no
surprise that the
brocus area is adjacent
to the motor cortex
that deals with the
mouth. So in the sensory
homunculus, you'll
see that this is where
the motor function of
the mouth is located.
As well as your
Wernicke's area
in the pink, that
is responsible
for understanding
of the speech.
If you have
lesions there,
you'll have
nonsensical speech.
And that's located
in the posterior
superior temporal gyrus.
So the Broca's area,
lesions there, is
called expressive
aphasia, affecting your
fluency. And lesions
of the Wernicke's
area causes receptive
aphasia, problems
with understanding.
Both of these areas
are supplied by the
distal cortical
branches of the MCA.
So now you guys
understand the answer is
middle cerebral artery.
Here the patient is
obviously having a
receptive aphasia, so it is
a ****** of the
Wernicke's area, not the
Broca's area. And you
can clearly see here,
this is the posterior
superior temporal gyrus
that is stroked out.
So that's a specific
distal portion of the
MCA that's infarcted.
Now we have arrived at
the favorite part of
my lecture, where we
get to talk about the
actual clinical pathologies
of these arteries
that we talked about.
We will cover the
intracranial bleeds.
For each of these
intracranial bleeds, I
want you guys to be able
to identify the location
of the bleed, the
cause of the bleed,
the presentation of the
patient when they
have these bleeds, and
radiological imaging,
specifically CT head.
I will be going over
this in more depth later
in the cerebrovascular
pathology lecture.
I just want to give
you guys a quick
overview of how to read
a CT scan. You will
not be specifically
tested on this slide,
but you'll be given
a picture of a CT
scan and be required
to understand what
kind of bleed it is.
So these are just
for your own references.
A CT of the head
is a density-based
scan. So different
colors of gray that
you will see is based
on different densities
of the matter.
The more white it is,
so that's when you
call it hyperdense.
So anything white on
the CT is referred
to as hyperdense.
Anything gray that is
the same color of the
gradient as the
brain, that's called
isodense. And darker
things that are darker
than the brain, it's
called hypodense. So
an acute bleed, which
is what we're talking
about for most of
the part of the next
few slides are acute
bleeds, those will
be white in the CT.
So we will say that
hyperdense lesion,
whereas a chronic bleed,
such as a chronic
subdural hematoma, will
be much darker, and
those are referred to
as hypodense lesions.
And you can also
have these bleeds over
time, they are in the
subacute period where
they're starting to
chronicize and are at
the same color as the
brain, and you usually
refer to them as
isodense lesions.
Again, you're not tested
on this. This is just
for your reference.
So we will go from
superficial to deep in
terms of the bleeds.
So to start with, you
have an epidural
hematoma, and as the name
suggests, it's epi
above the dura. So it's
formed, the clot is
formed between the
compartment of the
periosteal dura and the
skull. And this is due
to almost always, 99
% of the time, due to
a high-speed injury,
causes skull fracture,
especially in
the terioral temporal
region. And the
skull fracture causes
injury to the middle
meningeal artery,
which travels through
the inside grooves
of the skull. So
it tears the middle
meningeal artery,
and because it's an
artery, it has high
pressure, the bleed
builds up quickly.
For the presentation,
the patient usually
loses consciousness
right away when this
happens because of the
blast of blood forming
in the brain. And
then there's a lucid
period of time where
they're okay, people
think they're fine,
they usually go home
sometimes, which can
be fatal, because after
that lucid period,
because of the buildup
of bleed and compression
on the brain,
you usually rapidly
deteriorate. This
is a very high
emergency neurosurgical
intervention that
needs to be done.
On the CT scan, when
you put it on a bone
window, which is what
A is, you'll usually
see that skull fracture.
If you don't, then
usually 99% of the time,
it's not an epidural
hematoma. You need
that skull fracture.
And when you put it
in the brain window,
which is what it is,
you see that hyperdense
lesion. Remember,
hyperdense is acute bleed.
Whatever is white is
hyperdense, is acute
bleed compared to
the brain parenchyma.
And in the CT of the
head, you'll usually
see it as a lens-shaped
biconvex. And this
is because the bleed
is restricted between
where the dura attaches
to the sutures so
it doesn't travel it
stays within a region
now going deeper you
have the subdural
hematoma which forms
between the dura subdural
below the dura and the
arachnoid matter and
this is due to the the
bleed from bridging
veins that we mentioned
earlier so these are
tiny veins that traverses
through the dura
and in older people
when the brain shrinks
or chronic alcoholics
also have brain
shrinks, the bridging
veins have much more of a
tortuous root and they
can usually get torn
with like small
injuries. You don't have
to be high-speed trauma.
It could be a small
fall that causes
nicking of these small
bridging veins and
because this is a venous
bleed, this builds up
over time. So it's not
like a rapid presentation
like epidural
hematoma is. It's like
a very slower bleed that
symptoms takes hours
to weeks to develop.
And on a CT, you'll
see, again, this acute
bleed, which we said
is hyperdense lesion,
and it's more of a
crescent-shaped rather
than a lens-shaped as
in epidural hematoma.
This is because these
bleeds are not now
restricted by the dura
attaching to the suture,
so it can cross suture
lines. That's how
you can tell the
difference between epidural
hematoma and subdural
hematoma, where in
the epidural, it's
restricted within suture
lines, but subdural
hematoma, it can cross
suture lines because
it's below the dura.
Now, going more deeper,
you have the bleed
in the subarachnoid
space where the CSF
circulates, and
therefore it's called the
subarachnoid hemorrhage.
The most common reason
that this happens
is due to high-speed
trauma, but every time
you hear subarachnoid
hemorrhage, what you
will be tested on mostly
is for ruptured
aneurysms. Remember, we
said the aneurysms
that often develop in
the circular villus, which
is in the subarachnoid
space. So a rupture
of the aneurysm
of the circular villus
will cause blood to
be in the CSF. And the
classic presentation
is the thunderclap
headache, which is defined
as worst headache of
the patient's life,
which comes on maximum
intensity, worse
than pain of labor
without the epidural. And
it's associated with
neck stiffness and
photophobia, which is
usually because of the
meningeal irritation.
And in the CT head,
what you see is blood
in the subarachnoid
space. So here, this
is a classic starburst
pattern. If you see
this, don't even read
the question. It's
subarachnoid hemorrhage.
It's used to a ruptured
aneurysm of the
circle of villus very
heavily tested on the step
one and level one
bleed within the brain
matter or the parenchyma
of the brain is
called the intraparenchymal
or intracerebral
hematoma and the most
recent most common
reason for this is
hypertension and cerebral
amyloid angiopathy,
especially in older men.
And these causes lobar
hemorrhages, specifically
hemorrhage in
particular lobes of the
brain. And the
presentation will depend on
what part of the brain
is affected. So in
the left CT head, you
see lobar hemorrhage
in the, it's not a lobar
hemorrhage, actually,
this is a basal ganglia
hemorrhage, which
we talked about
before. This is the
lenticulostriate hemorrhage,
right, that affects
the basal ganglia and
called the Charcot
-Boujard aneurysm, so
most likely due to
hypertension. On the right,
you have a hemorrhage
within the cerebellum,
so maybe one of the
superior cerebellar
artery is hemorrhaged.
And on the
imaging, you will
see that hyperdense
lesion, which
again shows the
acute bleed.
And finally, you
have bleed within the
ventricles of the brain
called the intraventricular
hematoma. and this
can be primary
intraventricular
hematoma or hemorrhage or
secondary. So primary
is when the hemorrhage
starts within and
that's usually seen in
preterm infants because
of hemorrhage within
the germinal center
which we will talk about
in the cerebrovascular
pathology lecture.
If you see this in
adults it's usually an
extension from a
intraparenchymal hemorrhage
And this can often
cause obstruction
of the ventricular
system that we talked
about, right?
Obstructive hydrocephalus
and can have
symptoms that way.
And usually if we
see intraventricular
hemorrhage in a
neurosurgical setting,
the management will
depend on how the
patient is presenting,
but also usually
an EVD or an
extraventricular drain,
you put it in to
drain out the hematoma
out of the ventricles
is indicated.
On a CT, you will see
acute blood in the
ventricles. So this
is white. And if
you're asked to read
the CT, I would say
hyperdense lesion
within the ventricles.
All right, so let's
bring it all together
and do a clinical
question. Take
a second and see if
we can answer it.
so there are several
things in this vignette
that points out to
it being an epidural
hematoma so to
start with we have a
younger patients
involved in high-speed
trauma so likely had
a skull fracture that
caused the tearing of
the middle menageal
artery within that
skull inside the
groove and then he
had a initial loss of
consciousness which
is likely due to that
instant spraying of
blood over the cerebrum
because of that
arterial bleed which
can be a shock to
the system, and you
can lose consciousness
with that. And
then over time, it
recovers, so you have
that lucid interval
of being fine. And
then the patient is
showing rapid deterioration
and focal
neurological deficits.
He has hypertension
and bradycardia
and likely respiratory
irregularities.
That is called the
Cushing triad, which
is a response due
to high intracranial
pressure. And finally,
you have that lens
-shaped hyperdensity
that biconvex lesion,
hyperdense lesion
that you see in
epidural hematoma,
all of which is due to
the tearing of middle
meningeal artery.
So this is a likely
question, a similar
question that you
will see in your
comp and your level
one and step one.
And that brings us to
our end of the lecture.
here is your summary
slides rest of
the summary slides
please look over this
make sure you have
clear understanding of
everything if you guys
have any questions
please feel free to
email me my email is
right here thank you
so much for sticking
until the end I know
this is a long and heavy
lecture but repetition
is key and look
at different pictures
pictures can be very
helpful for all of
neuroanatomy good luck
also please take
the time to fill out
this survey so
that i know how to
improve my future
lectures thank you